[Applause]
you want to go inside its Stormy's world
and we're just living in it Kylie Jenner
went all out for her daughter's second
birthday bash on Saturday and we mean
all out she's gonna try world's frozen
worlds the stormy world first look at
these maps kylie straight-up built a
full-on stormy themed amusement park
called stormy world which is of course a
play on her dad Travis Scott's astral
world
[Music]
Kylee went with the same theme last year
but this year's party tagline reminded
guests that two is better than one and
two looks pretty freakin great
there were carnival rides bounce houses
and a stormy world shop and stormy space
was all over that place like literally
from the second you walked into the
party through a giant inflatable stormy
there's someone walking around the party
with a giant stormy head on which feels
kind of strange but okay then there's
this one of those arcade toy grabbing
thingies filled with stormy pillows
there was a giant stormy slide and a
fake stormy roller coaster and just
check out the sweets table complete with
a stormy centerpiece and stormy cookies
[Music]
Travis was even rocking a hoodie with
Stormies face all over the back damn
that's a lot of stormy partygoers could
also enjoy the day at frozen world or
trolls world with life-sized characters
from each of the kid flicks and
naturally the guestlist was stacked with
celebs Rosalia Winnie Harlow
the kanji lady she's ready freakin and
Hailey Bieber were all in attendance
[Music]
cardi B's sister Hennessy came and
brought along cardies daughter culture
and chrissy teigen who showed up to the
bash with her hubby John Legend and
daughter Luna shared this clip writing
oh my [ __ ] god
[Music]
and of course it wouldn't be a
Kardashian party without a whole lot of
Kardashian Khloe and her daughter true
were they're sober Chris and Kendall
Jenner Rob Kardashian's daughter dream
and Kim and her kids North st. and
Chicago
Kylie clearly takes her role as mama
super seriously and she recently told
Kim during their makeup tutorial that
she sees herself having a few more
kiddos I see myself for sure having four
kids I just don't know when I don't have
the timeline to this and I don't know if
I'm gonna have four kids tomorrow from
there for thirteen weeks seven years how
cute is that of course you can count on
et to bring you all the latest on Kylie
and stormy so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]